اسبوع مشرق نبداه بمفهوم الراحه ونبحث عن
الرقم السحري كم يجب ان نخصص من وقتنا
لراحتنا
يقفز مباشره من السرير ويبدا اليوم بنشاط
واخرون يشعرون بالخمول وذلك لاننا قد نكون
حصلنا على قسم من النوم ولكن لم يتحقق
الشعور بالراحه ضغوط الحياه الحديثه يمكن
ان تؤدي الى انقاص الفتره المخصصه للراحه
الكثيرون لا يعرفون مقدار ما يحتاجون اليه
من الراحه بالتالي يدفعون الثمن متمثلا في
انخفاض الاداء وكذلك المرض
ما نشره موقع ستايلست البريطاني يجد
الخبراء ان 42% من اليوم هو المقدار الذي
يحتاج فيه المرء الى الراحه اما الانشطه
المختلفه فيجب ان تنحصر في عشر ساعات فقط
الزميل لميس ابراهيم تطلعنا اكثر على
انواع الراحه في حياتنا وقاعده
42% سر القاعده لديك الراحه ثم الراحه ثم
الراحه والله يلا على ايدك يمكن تعريف
الراحه على انها اي سلوك يهدف الى زياده
الرفاهيه الجسديه او العقليه فيمكن ان
تكون عن طريق النشاط البدني مثل الخروج
للمشي او الاسترخاء مثل اخذ عشر دقائق
للجلوس والتنفس بع
مق قد يكون من الصعب تحديد معنى الراحه
لكن الدكتوره
تحددتها في سبعه انواع وهي الراحه
الابداعيه والعقليه والجسديه والاجتماعيه
والعاطفيه والحسيه والروحيه وسيحتاج الشخص
على الارجح الى القليل من جميع هذه
الانواع حتى يعمل بشكل جيد والاتباع قاعده
42% راحه في اليوم تقترح الدراسه تقسيم
يوم كما يليق ثماني ساعات من النوم 20 الى
30 دقيقه من محادثات تقليل التوتر مع شريك
الحياه او قريب او صديق 30 دقيقه من نشاط
البدني 30 دقيقه من الاهتمام بالطعام فتره
حره مدتها 30 دقيقه حسب الاحتياجات
[موسيقى]
معنى الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الدكتوره
كارلا خليل اختصاصيه علم النفس العصبي
الكلينيكي اهلا بك دكتوره كارلمان صباح
الراحه يا دكتوره شكرا دكتوره يعني
الحقيقه هاي الدراسه وهذا التمييز ما بين
الراحه والنوم شيء مثير للاهتمام لانه
احنا عاده نربط الراحه بالنوم وكنا بنعرف
عن مخاطر قله النوم على توازن الهرموني في
الدماغ على العمل الدماغ حتى الصحه
النفسيه الاعضاء الجسم ولكن ما لم نكن
نعرفه بانه حتى لو اخذنا قصه كامل من
النوم ثمان ساعات في النهار ولكن ما زلنا
بحاجه للمزيد من الراحه هاتينا اكثر يعني
شو الفرق ما بين هاي الراحه وهاي الراحه
هلق هون احنا صرنا كم سنه دايما عم نحط
مثل ما قلتي النوم والراحه بنفس
المكان وكم مره نحن بنكون نمنا 8 اوقات
تسع ساعات
انه اليوم كمان مت كفايه بكرا بجرب نام
ساعه زياده الدراسه اللي بينته مش كثير
مهم لانه اليوم اذا منتطلع على متطلبات
الحياه اليوم متطلبات الحياه عم بتزيد كل
ما الها عم بتصير اكبر واعلى يمكن
اجتماعيا يمكن عاطفيا عمليا بالشغل بالبيت
وهذا من الاشخاص اللي صغار بالعمر يعني
بشوفهم بالعياده جايين وعندهم متطلبات
نشاطيه عندهم متطلبات اجتماعيه عندهم
متطلبات بالمدرسه النوم ما بكفي تنقدر
نستعيد الانرجي تبعنا لكل هالمتطلبات
الموجوده نحن نعرف انه النوم كتير مهم مش
بس عدد الساعات المنامه بس كمان الجدول
اللي بنحترمه لانه عنا الساعه البيولوجيه
لازم لازم نحترمها نقدر نكون في استمراريه
بمستويات النشاط بس هذا الشيء ما بكفي ليه
لانه اليوم كم مره نحنا قطعنا بنهار بنقول
اليوم احكي مع حدا اليوم
جاهز انه فوت بجي بيجات او فوت بمشاكل او
جرب حل الامور لانه ما حطينا
الراحه العاطفيه تبعنا الدراسه بتبين انه
حل من الحلول تنكون عاطفيا اكثر مثلا نقبل
نقول انه انا اليوم ماني مرتاح ما نجبر
حالنا نقول انه امبلا انا قادر اليوم اعمل
اللي بدكم اياه مع انه كان في فتره ماضيه
انه الحديث مع العقل الباطن بانه اقنعه
انه انت قادر على انجاز هذا الشيء هو شيء
ايجابي وليس نكران ايضا في الامر الاخر ما
المقصود بالراحه هل هي الراحه الجسديه ام
الذهنيه طيب الراحه الجسديه فيها تكون من
النوم
بالمشي البطيء بس الراحه الذهنيه كثير
مهمه
يعني مثلا اليوم عم نحكي عن الراحه
الاجتماعيه وكل
المتطلبات الاجتماعيه والمتطلبات العاطفيه
كتير مربوطين انا اليوم بسله محل ماني
قادر اعطي اجتماعيا بقول ماني قادر اعطي
اجتماعيا وباخد شوي بريك بارجع اشرس في
كمان متطلبات حسيه ما بندركها خلينا ناخذ
العلقه بنفكر احنا وقت مهدور بس بهذا
الوقت جسمنا حواسنا دائما على
كل شيء الراديو يلي ماشي الاصوات اذا في
ولد بالسياره الوقت كله متطلبات ذهنيه
اكثر بكثير من متطلبات جسديه بس دكتوره
كيف بدنا نتفادى كل هذا ما انت حتى لو
قاعد في البيت لوحدك ما فيش اي
معيقات حواليك يعني وممكن برضو تتعرض لعدم
راحه ذهنيه فكيف ممكن بالاستمراريه اذا
فينا ناخذ كمثل يلي بده يركض مرات
اذا ركضوا نهار السباق بيقدر ياخده
بحياتنا اليوميه كل يوم
كيف نريح دهننا سريعه كل ساعتين احنا ناخذ
بريك خمس دقايق نزيح عن
نسكر الحواس نحط جرن الحد التخت نكتب فيه
الافكار يلي بتزعجنا اللي ما بتخلينا ننام
هيك بنظهرهم من ذهب
بحطهم بحياتهم اليوميه بس باستمراريه
للمتطلبات فائقه يقدر يقطع هالنهار بلا ما
يحس بحبها كثير كبير اذا هي تفريغ هذه
الشحنات اللي موجوده بالتالي على ورق كما
تقول الدكتوره كارلا خليل اختصاصيه علم
النفس العصبي شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
شكرا
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات